we have a voicemail number, that number is
two one nine two David P..
Here's a voicemail about whatever happened
to that payroll tax cut calling from Texas.
No one's talking about.
The fact that the Republicans are not doing
the payroll tax cut right now, that they're
not for it.
Right.
In my opinion is because they know once Joe
Biden is confirmed as president, should he
get the nomination?
That he is going to do the payroll tax cut
and the blood will be on the Democrats hands.
I'm not so sure about that.
I think Republicans are in favor of the payroll
tax cut, but they recognize that there's a
good chance nothing happens if that becomes
the sticking point.
I also I'm just not sure that Joe Biden is
going to do it.
So I I'm I'm interested in the way in which
the payroll tax cut stuff has imploded on
Trump.
But I don't know that I agree with this particular
analysis.
But let me know what you think.
Is this caller onto something?
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Russia's looking to approve a corona virus
vaccine within weeks, according to a new report.
Trump's looking at banning Tick-Tock in the
United States.
And we will talk about the lack of resources
for a lot of people who want to vote by mail.
What do I mean by that?
We will discuss it.
Get instant access to the bonus show by becoming
a member at join Pacman dot com or a patron
at Patrie on dot com slash David Pakman show.